merci à vous moi je retiens un mot alors
entièrement qui me paraît essentiel
c'est confiance parce qu'effectivement
je crois que c'est par la confiance
qu'on arrivera à avancer et puis
l'entreprise 7 au service de l'homme et
je crois que c'est une valeur qui est
partagé par l'ensemble des chefs
d'entreprise et et beaucoup d'ailleurs
de salariés également je vais passer la
parole à mon collègue jean charles
taugourdeau qui avant d'être député
était un chef d'entreprise et qui va
donc nous donner son lait je vois aussi
que tu parles du temps de travail du
temps non mais c'est une entreprise
devenue débuté moi j'ai bien pu
constater que l'interventionnisme
législatif est quand même un obstacle au
retour au renversement normatif en
faveur de des accords collectifs et a
fortiori aussi des accords d'entreprise
il ya cinq domaines dans lesquels
justement la loi fait obstacle vraiment
à ce renversement normatif c'est le
contrat de travail de non pas le contrat
de travail si le contrat de travail sa
signature et sa rupture la durée du
travail
vous avez aussi le travail le travail du
dimanche
vous avez le droit de grève et le
représentativité syndicale et en os de
toutes ses normes en haut de cette
pyramide ya pas la pareille à la
constitution ensuite il ya la loi
ensuite il ya les règlements ensuite il
ya les accords nationaux
interprofessionnels
ensuite il y a les accords collectifs
ensuite les accords d'entreprise et les
accords et ensuite voilà au final le
contrat de travail avec la norme du
dessus qui s'impose à la norme du tout
aux comprenez que
tout en bas by un chef d'entreprise qui
rêvent de pouvoir mettre en place dans
son entreprise des accords d'entreprise
l'accord d'entreprise comme je le vois
c'est les salariés qui votent
qu'il y ait ou pas de syndicat c'est pas
un problème qui est peu ou beaucoup de
salariés c'est pas un problème tous les
salariés le vote est obligatoire pendant
les heures de travail
on compte les bulletins blancs c'est à
dire que si si majoritairement il est
des bulletins blancs c'est le chef
d'entreprise a pas un bon projet mais il
faut qu'il y ait 50 % des salariés
qu'ils disent oui au projet et ça c'est
pour moi c'est l'essentiel
alors trop on a voté trop de lois
l'exception c'est la règle on dit
toujours mais l'excès de loi finalement
à d a détruit la règle du bon sens et le
bon sens c'est quand il ya du travail on
le fait il faut pouvoir le faire il faut
pas nous interdire de le faire quel que
soit le jour l'heure et la durée la
durée du travail on le fait et à partir
s'il n'y a pas de travail dont on se
repose on prépare la tranche d'après et
si vraiment il n'ya pas de travail dont
on va en chercher du travail chez un
autre employeur
voire un troisième employeur parce que
ça existe aussi aujourd'hui les
groupements d'employeurs la
surprotection la surprotection de
l'emploi ça clairement a détruit le
travail
92 % des tpe disent que le frein aux
licenciements
enfin la difficulté de licenciés c'est
un véritable frein à l'embauché alors
libérer le travail s'est libéré
l'entrepreneur mais s'est aussi libéré
le salarié qui trouvera plus facilement
une entreprise la grosse différence
entre le code du travail français et le
code du travail suisse il ya deux
différences majeures c'est pas le nombre
de pages c'est pas le nombre d'articles
c'est pas l'épaisseur
c'est pas le poids c'est juste les
accords d'entreprise à prat pratiquement
à la fin de chaque votation à la fin de
chaque obligation dans le code suisse il
y a sauf accord d'entreprise
et aussi une chose qu'on n'a pas nous
c'est la facilité pour licencier c'est
très clair donc un entrepreneur libéré
c'est il n'aura il aura à coeur de
développer son entreprise donc de créer
du travail c'est le travail crée
l'emploi et donc le salarié se trouve
sécurisée parce que la meilleure façon
de sécuriser un salarié c'est tip is a
world du travail
oui j'accélère libéré libéré c'est aussi
l'accompagner parce que pas un contrôle
systématique pour sanctionner avec
toutes les pièces qu'il faut libérer
d'entrepreneurs quand on voit toutes les
pièces y compris pour contrôler le
salarié d'ailleurs alors que dire quand
on voit aujourd'hui que pour obtenir
demander et obtenir le rsa il faut
simplement une déclaration sur l'honneur
donc il faudrait qu'on puisse arriver à
dire un jour que en france on embête que
ceux qui travaillent et le chef
d'entreprise devenu député je trouve
qu'on va toujours dans la bonne
direction c'est vrai au niveau des
républicains c'est donner de la
visibilité de la sécurité juridique aux
chefs d'entreprise à nos entrepreneurs
je reviendrai pas sur la définition de
l'entrepreneur celui qui met 1 euros de
sa poche mais je fais court je pense que
j'ai fait vraiment très court ce qu'il
faut c'est les aimer les laisser
travailler
alors en ce qui concerne le temps de
travail le temps de travail moi je le
vois défini par des accords dans
l'entreprise si on a une entreprise avec
des activités ultra saisonnière on peut
pas ne pas déroger au repos quotidien
quand on fait 10 % du volume de l'année
en quelques jours
voilà donc je n'en resterai là mais au
niveau du comité des entrepreneurs on
pourra reprendre un petit peu en détail
tout ça